actually have a funny story [ __ ] okay no
no because like
because like okay this is this was like
when i was a kid right and
you know with like when you first
discover like the concept of like sex
and porn
and like i didn't like we had dial-up
internet back then yeah same so
yeah but like this this was this was
going back when i was like 9
10 you know yeah before before i could
really like
have time to work on a computer and
everything like that so
um i would like the only way i could get
anything close to that was by watching
like late night tv shows
right okay in in the uk so
um so what i tried to do as a kid was i
would
like i would record shows on my vhs
i did that as well right right okay okay
but there's but there was this one show
because i looked at the tv guide there
was this one show
what i did there was this one show that
was like oh this sounds spicy as a kid
i'm like
oh this this sounds exactly what i'm
looking for it was a late night tv show
edit like 12.
is it is it can i say the title is it
okay is it called babe station
no no no that was the one okay
i'm gonna talk about that that way i
probably i probably would would have
enjoyed babe station no
okay babe station more no the show was
called sex in the city
so me being a nine-year-old kid thinking
i'm about to get porn right now
and then i i said i set my vhs up i
i go to sleep the vhs records and i've
never been
more disappointed as a kid like imagine
it as a kid
you think you're about to get full-on
sex for the first time you could assume
and the city right and you just get a
bunch of girls talking about
dick and shoes like i i was like what
what is this this is false advertising
do you know how much effort i had to put
in to record this show and this is what
i get
i i remember as well as like as like a
12 year old 13 year old and just hearing
that like my mom's friend
whose favorite show was sex in the scene
i was like that's not very christian of
you
what the [ __ ] man adults are scary